[VIDEO GAME MUSIC]
Hey, everyone.
What's up?
It's Rob Dodson.
Welcome to a very special
I/O edition of "Polycast."
Today, we're going to talk about
styling and theming elements
and how all that
just got way better
in the new release of Polymer.
I really think you're
going to enjoy this,
so let's check it out.
So I'm going to start with a
little story about Polymer 0.5,
because this is an issue that
tripped up a lot of folks.
In Polymer 0.5, if you
had a component that
had some internal
styles and then
you had some more specific
CSS styles in the document,
when you took that component
over to polyfilled browsers
like Safari or
Internet Explorer,
you might see one thing
and then in Chrome,
where there's native
Shadow DOM, you
would see something different.
In other words, if you had more
specific CSS in the document,
it could totally
wreck your component.
And this tripped up a lot of
beginners who were just getting
started with Polymer and
thought perhaps it just
didn't work in all browsers,
which is not the case.
It's just it's very, very
difficult to properly polyfill
CSS scoping.
So let me give you an example
of what this looks like,
just so you can kind
of internalize it.
In one of the previous
episodes of "Polycast,"
we created this
quick alert tag here,
which is basically like
a little notification
you might send to a user.
And in that episode, I wanted
to style this div down here,
so I used this alert style.
But imagine if, instead of
using a class selector here,
if I just styled the
div element by itself.
Now, this is totally fine.
This would give us
that same example.
The problem is just that
it's not very specific.
And so what could
happen is my buddy
might be working somewhere
else in the site,
totally oblivious
to what I'm doing.
And he might create an
alert class, as well, just
to target some other
element on the page.
And he could style it with
some weird fonts and background
colors and what have you.
And then, when I go
in the next morning,
I look at my quick alert
tag, it's all busted.
It's in Comic Sans.
It looks all messed up.
And for a lot of
folks, they saw this
and they just thought, oh,
this stuff just doesn't work.
But really, the problem is,
you just can't very effectively
polyfill CSS scoping.
It's a pretty
tricky thing to do.
But the team decided
perhaps there
could be a better alternative
to what we currently had.
And so I'm happy to introduce
you to the new custom style
tag.
Now, this is a type extension
of the style element.
If you recall in a
previous episode,
we talked all about
type extension elements
and how they work.
And the cool thing about
the custom style tag
is it allows you to put your
document CSS inside of it
and these styles are
basically not going
to be able to affect or mess
up any of the components
that you have on your page
in polyfilled browsers.
It's a really great way
to get lower bound style
scoping in Polymer in
the newest release.
I think it's pretty awesome.
So now you know how to
protect your elements
from document-level styles
in polyfilled browsers,
the next thing I
want to show you
is how to actually theme
whole element sets using
some cool new techniques.
Now, in last year's I/O, I
showed off a couple of ways
that you could theme
an element using
some shadow piercing selectors.
So there was ::shadow
pseudo element,
which would allow you to pierce
one level into the shadow
boundary and in this example,
target the slider knob thing
inside of my paper slider.
There was also the
deep combinator,
which allows you to pierce
infinite levels of shadow
boundaries.
And in this case, I'm targeting
all the little ink effects
inside of here by
actually hitting the ID.
But there are some problems
with ::shadow and /deep/.
First and foremost, they
totally break encapsulation.
In those examples, I had to know
specific ID names of elements
inside of my web
components to target them,
which means if the author moved
those things around or changed
the names at any point,
my theme would break.
Also, ::shadow and /deep/ kind
of screw up some potential
performance gains.
There's this idea that you can
improve style recalculation
using Shadow DOM, if it wasn't
possible to pierce inside
of it.
But that sort of
goes out the window.
And lastly, and I think
this is pretty important,
both ::shadow and /deep/
are sort of imprecise tools.
They're kind of
like sledgehammers.
In particular, /deep/ is
kind of a main offender here,
because it can pierce so many
levels and do so many things.
So the team thought
that perhaps there
would be a better way to
do theming and styling
in the new release of Polymer.
And one of the areas
that we've been exploring
is around CSS variables.
So let me show you an example
of how this could work.
I've got an element that I've
created here called UI message
and it is pretty generic.
It's got a container and then
a header and content area
inside of it.
And it's just got some data
bindings to these properties
down here that I've created.
Now, I'm going to hide
my JavaScript definition,
just so I can focus
on the markup up here.
And I want to add some styles.
So I'm going to target the host
and give it an inline block
style.
I'm also going to
target that container
and set its background color
to gray and with a little bit
of padding.
And this is going to give me a
very generic-looking sort of UI
message thing.
Now, it's pretty
boring, but let's say
someone actually wanted to
use this in their project.
And the first thing
they wanted to do
was change that header color.
So to do that using
CSS variables,
we can actually target
the header class,
target the color property, and
then give it a variable here.
So I'm saying that the value
of UI message header color
should set my color property.
Now, I know that this
syntax is pretty funky,
but this is the syntax-- this
is the standard syntax for CSS3
variables.
And the cool thing
about this is it
allows the author
to expose a styling
point to the outside world.
But someone using this
component doesn't actually
need to know specifically where
this variable is being used.
They just know that there's
a header color variable
somewhere that gets applied.
So elsewhere, I'm creating
a theme for this component.
I've got a custom style element.
And it's very important that
if you're using variables,
that you place them inside
of custom style elements,
because it gives Polymer
one place to look
for these variable declarations.
I'm going to target
the UI message tag,
that variable,
and I'll pass in
a value of white.
And what that's going to do is
give me a header that is white.
Now, this is really cool,
because as a consumer
of the element, I don't
need to know anything
about the internals.
I can just set a value
for that variable
and then the author can choose
to use it however they wish.
But there's a catch here.
If we have to define a variable
for every single property
inside of our
element, then we're
going to end up with thousands
of variables and no time
and we definitely
don't want that.
So this is where things actually
get kind of interesting.
The Polymer team's been working
on an experimental new theming
system that takes advantage
of CSS custom properties.
It's experimental, like I
said, but totally awesome.
So I want to show
you how that works.
Now, one of the things
that would be cool
is if we could pass in not
just one variable at a time,
but actually pass in a
whole bunch of properties
all at once.
There is a concept
similar to this in CSS
preprocessors like SaaS
or Less called mixins.
And this is something
that the Polymer team
has been working with
the CSS standards body
to add to the current spec.
It's this idea of taking
custom properties that
allow you to pass in whole
bags of values all at once.
So let me show you
how that works,
because it's pretty cool.
So let's take our
header thing here
and instead of just
doing this one variable,
I'm going to create a few what
are called custom properties.
So I've still got my
sort of default styles
that I started
with my container,
but now I'm using
this syntax to say,
hey, I want to apply a custom
property called UI message
container theme.
I'm going to apply a UI message
header theme and a content
theme.
And what this allows me to do
is go back to my theme file
and replace this one variable
with those custom properties.
Notice that there's a
semicolon on the end here.
This is important for
the syntax and something
that I often leave off.
And now, I can actually pass in
just whole bags of properties
that I would like to
override the default
styles in that element.
Now, I borrowed these styles
from the Symantic UI Library
just to show that you
can go hog wild here.
You can pass in as much CSS
as you could possibly imagine.
And what this is
going to do is take
our totally boring,
vanilla UI message
and turn it into
something that's
actually much more pleasant.
So over in my Code Editor, I've
got a Bower JSON file fired up
and I am in my dependencies
listing Polymer 0.9 RC.1 as one
of my dependencies.
Now, it's been a few weeks
since this has been recorded,
so you're probably
safe at this point
to just go ahead and replace
this with the actual 0.9.0 tag.
And once you've got that in
place, you can install it.
It'll pull down the
latest version of Polymer.
And over in my UI
message file, this
is the same element that I was
showing over in the slides.
And the first thing
I'm going to do
is create a little
header variable.
And that's just
going to allow me
to change the color of
this header down here.
I can create a My Theme HTML
file and add a custom style
element to that.
I can create a My Theme HTML
file and add a custom style
element to that.
And inside of here, I'm going
to target the UI message element
and I'll pass in a
value for that variable.
And now when I'm ready
to use these guys,
I can just import the
definition for my UI message
and import the theme
that I just created.
And then, I can just drop the
UI message tag on the page
and that theme is going
to be applied to it.
So if I hop over to Chrome,
we'll see my message
and we see that
updated header color.
Now, let's try to do this
with some custom properties.
So we'll go back to
our element definition.
And instead of just
the one variable,
I'm going to use
the @ apply syntax
to create custom properties
for container theme, header
theme, and content theme.
And then, back in
My Theme HTML file,
I can replace this one variable
with those custom properties.
Again, note the semicolons here.
I always forget
to include those.
And then, I'll just Paste
in a bunch of CSS styles.
Again, these are the styles that
I borrowed from Symantec UI,
but you can see that--
pass in whatever you want,
box shadow and color and
opacity, what have you.
All of these are
going to be applied
and they're going to
override the defaults that
are in that UI message element.
So you go back to Chrome
and Refresh the page.
And now, things are
looking much nicer.
Now, this is a huge
improvement over where
we were with theming and
styling in previous versions
of Polymer.
And personally, I'm just
really excited to see
what you all build with it.
That's it for today.
Be sure to click little
subscribe button.
Leave me questions
down in the comments.
As always, thank you
so much for watching
and I'll see you next time.
[VIDEO GAME MUSIC]
Hey there,
Polycasters, Rob here.
Q&A time-- a Lucas Ciruzzi
sends in three questions.
The first is, is the
underscore notation
mandatory when you're defining
an observer in your properties
object?
It's a good question, Lucas.
The underscore is
actually not mandatory.
That's just something
that we include
to signify that a
function is private
and that we don't want
the outside world calling
that method.
But by no means is it required.
It's just sort of
a stylistic thing.
Second question-- how would you
implement an attribute change
listener on a native web
component, so something that
isn't using Polymer or
anything like that, just
a vanilla custom element?
To do that, you can use the
attribute change callback.
That is a lifecycle callback
that every custom element has.
And that callback
is going to give you
three arguments, the
attribute name that changed,
the old value,
and the new value.
Last question is, how does
the read-only property
affect a custom element
when I change that protected
property from the outside using
something like set attribute?
In that case, what
you're going to see
is the DOM element
is going to update,
but the property inside of it
is going to remain the same.
So if you have a binding to
that property or something
like that, that binding is
going to stay exactly as it was.
So great questions, Lucas.
Thank you for sending those in.
If you have questions,
please leave them for us
down in the comments.
We'll try to answer them all--
maybe feature you on the show
and give you some swag.
As always, thanks
so much for watching
and I'll see you next time.